les ombres sont rares et le soleil au
zénith
du coup personne dehors il y à bien
longtemps que les vaches laitières se
sont réfugiés dont le bâtiment d'élevage
de 2000 m² ici elles peuvent manger
tranquillement 12 ventilateur et 3
brumisateur veille au grain il se
déclenche automatiquement
on a préparé avec la décision d'investir
27 mille euros dans notre système de
ventilation pour avoir une unité
ventilés sur toute la surface
l'apport de brumisation pour baisser la
température on met 3 4 degrés quand la
brumisation s'enclenche ces éleveurs
sont des précurseurs
la ventilation est gérée automatiquement
la traite des vaches est assurée par un
robot le lisier nettoyé par un deuxième
robot et l'alimentation assurée par un
troisième le prix de la tranquillité et
le bien-être des animaux alimentés
baisser la production glay
conny sa troupe a plu et qui se couche
plus dans le lisier
on a beaucoup moins de mammites des
infections ma merde et aussi au niveau
reproduction sami faible à garder les
embryons viable depuis peu des experts
de la chambre d'agriculture de loire et
cher sillonne la campagne avec de drôles
d'appareils de mesure la cartographie et
de pouvoir vous mais sur des zones de
confort et d'un confort pour les animaux
et pouvoir ainsi confié l'éleveur
sur certains investissements là il peut
avoir des aides les aides de l'europe et
du conseil régional ne sont pas
négligeables jusqu'à 20% des dépenses